مساء الخير لو سالت حدا على الارجح في اي
مكان في العالم ماذا تعرف عن سلطنه بروناي
الكعبه في الغالب تكون بلد غني جدا وسلطان
يعيش في قصور من ذهب عيش الف ليله وليله
لان تباعد ربما لا يكون دقيق تماما ولكنه
ليس خاطئا ايضا ولا انه ليس خاطئه كانت
علامات الاستفهام كبيره لهذا البلد ولهذا
السلطان اللي بيعيشها حكايات الف ليله
وليله
يفادي العالم بالاعلان عن تطبيق الشريعه
الاسلاميه تطبيقا كاملا بما فيها الحدود
الامر اللي هو مدرك تماما ان دول العالم
القويه والغربيه سوف ترفضه قلبا وقالبا
وهو ما حدث عملوا حملات مقاطعه وانتقادات
واسع عليه سلفهم دوافع السلطان لازم ناخذ
فكره الاول عن بروناي كافيا واقتصاديا و
تاريخيا وسياسيا
بايجاز شديد كده بقى الجغرافيا افتح اكتشف
انه بروناي اللي احنا بنتكلم عليها من
عشرات السنين باعتبارها رمز للثراء هي
جزيره صغيره جدا صغير جدا من جزيره بورنيو
اللي هي واحده تعتبر ثالث اكبر جزيره في
العالم من حيث المساحه في المحيط الهادي
وتحديدا يعني ب تطل على بحر الصين الجنوبي
اه الجزيره فيها جزء كبير من ماليزيا وجزء
كبير من اندونيسيا وفي صغير جدا لا يتجاوز
سته الاف كيلومتر مربع هذا الجزء هو اللي
سلطنه بروناي تاريخيا بروناي كانت سلطنه
بتمارس نفسها على مساحه اكبر من منطقه
برميل لكن هذا ما تبقى منها في العصر
الحديث طيب السلطنه دي اه بتعيش يعني هي
اثريه
بالنفط والغاز والنفط والغاز بيمثله
تسعين في المائه من اكثر من تسعين في من
صادرات الكثيره بتمثل اكثر من تسعين في
المائه من الدخل الحكومه وكل تقريبا الشعب
يعمل في الجهاز الحكومي وبالتالي الحكومه
تنفق على الشعب من مداخيل البترول الحقيقه
من المهم نعرف انه رغم كل الكلام عن فراغ
هي الناتج المحلي الاجمالي لها في 2017
كان اطناشر مليار وثلاثمائه مليون
وده رقم يعادل 1 على 10 من الدخل المحلي
الاجمالي لبلده السودان اللي كان الناطق
بتاع وفي نفس العام 117 مليار ناصر وثلاثه
من عشره دوله تقريبا يعدلوا اه ربع الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي البلد في تونس اللي كان
الناتج المحلي في نفس العام حوالي اربعين
واربعين مليار قبلي هذا البلد يوصف
بالثراء رغم الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
المتواضع بتاعه ببساطه لانه هو الثرى وفقا
لمعيار نصيب او متوسط نصيب الفرد من
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
يعني هما يكسبوا هو الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي الاثناش ثلاثه عشره لكن عدد
السكان
اربعه اربعمائه وثلاثين الف مواطن فقط
وبالتالي لنتيجه حسابها بلد زي مصر الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي حوالي مائتين واربعين
مليار لكنها مقصره على مائه مليون
فيما انه اللي ناصر وثلاثه من عشره مليار
سلطنه بروناي موزعه على اربع مائه وثلاثين
ما يعني انه نصيب الفرد حوالي ثلاثين الف
دولار في السنه مقابل بلد زي مصر اقتصاد
بروناي حوالي خمسه وعشرين مره لكن نصيب
الفرد حوالي ثلاثه الاف ونص دولار تقريبا
السبب الارتباط سلطنه بروناي بالثراء
وبالمناسبه السلطان واحد من اكثر الناس
سواء في العالم دائما التقارير الفوز
وغيرها بتتحدث انه عنده ثروه
وعشرين مليار دولار بالنسبه لي اقتصاديا
وهو رفع تاريخيين السلطنه
هي تاريخ طويل
مع الاسلام ومع المسلمين الاسلام دخلها
بشكل مبكر والمؤرخين بال مختلفين داخلها
في القرن العاشر القرن 12 القرن ال 15 في
كل الاحوال كان الخلاف احنا عندنا بدايه
نهايه القرن ال 14 ظهر عندنا السلطان محمد
شاه اللي هو اول سلطان او او لحاكم اعتنق
الاسلام هناك يسمي نفسه محمد شاء وبدا
التاريخ الحديث اللي احنا نعرفه ليبرون اي
اللي موجوده في الوقت الحالي والحقيقه ان
السلطنه مش بس انها اعتنقت الاسلام لعبت
دور كبير جدا ابناء بروناي في نشر الاسلام
في دول جنوب شرق اسيا
في عدد من ال اه ال ال ال العرب والمسلمين
خرجوا من الجزيره العربيه ومن غيرها لعب
دور في نشر الاسلام في الدول المحيطه من
خلال بروناي منهم مثلا شخصيه اسمه شريفه
على نخرج من الطائف ويقال انه من نسل
الرسول عليه الصلاه والسلام مساعد فى نشر
الاسلام فى بروم ايوا الدول المحيطه كل ده
ال يعني
خلفيه ايه هي وزرائها ووضعها لكن الحقيقه
فيه ثلاث متغيرات مؤخرا مهمين جدا مهم
فيما يتعلق ببرنامج اولمت غير مباشر انه
الاقتصاد
الرائد او الممتاز للبرميل متاثر بشده
ويعاني من كساد مش بس انه نسب النمو ضعيفه
داب السالم يعني تنكمش يعني عاده الاقتصاد
بينم بينم كثيره على سلطنه بروناي بتعاني
من ان كباش يعني يعني اه ال النمو بالسلم
هو السبب الاساسي هو حاجتين الحاجه
الاولنيه انه هي تاثرت ب تراجع اسعار
النفط على مدار السنه القليله الماضيه
وبما انه هي تعتمد بشكل اساسي على البترول
في اي تغير في اسعار البترول ينعكس عليها
بشكل كبير فالنتيجه انه عندنا تراجع
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي ليها مثلا من 2012
كان الناتج المحلي اكثر من تسعطاشر مليار
انخفضت الى حوالي ال 2017 الى اطناشر
مليار مشترك السلطنه اكبر من مجرد مشكله
انخفاض اسعار البترول اللي بتعاني منه كل
الدول النفطيه مشكلتها اكبر انه التقارير
والشركات الدوليه ادركت تماما انه الثروه
الكبيره البترول والغاز اخذه في النوم
والتوقعات ان هذه الصوره سوف تمضي ب خلال
عقدين من الزمان يعني بيتكلم على الفين
مثلا واربعين او حاجه زي كده وبالتالي فيه
مشكله كبيره جدا من السلطنه ال ال الامر
الثالث انه الاعتبار الثالث انه ال ثاني
اسف يعني غير انه الاقتصاد تتراجع بشكل
كبير كمان فيه مشكله مشكله ان وفي صعود في
التيارات السلفيه والتيارات المحافظه فيما
في بروناي وفيه جنوب شرق اسيا بصفه عامه
اذا كنت تعتقد انه فيه صعود الطيارات
المتشدده في الدول العربيه
يمكن تراجع نفسك لو عرفت حجم التشدد في
فهم الاسلام والدين في دول جنوب شرق اسيا
و ديكو مثال واحد بس انه في الفلبين كانت
منطقه مراوي الحكومه من حوالي سنه وسنتين
بتستخدم السلاح الثقيل لمحاوله في محاوله
للسيطره على مجموعه من المتشددين الراغبين
في الانفصال واعلان الاماره الاسلاميه بعد
ان اعلام البيعه لابي بكر البغدادي
عامل ثاني العامل الثالث هو انه سلطه
النفس وتغير والسلطان اللي كان رمزا
السلطاني اللي هو العامل
يعني
او مغامرات وبدا الصحف الغربيه يبلغ الان
هو بدا يحكمان السلطنه من سنه سبعه وستين
الان يبلغ ثلاثه وسبعين سنه ووفقا
للتقارير اللي يعني بتصدر عن المجالس يبدو
انه اكثر رغبه الان في انه يكون اكثر
تدينا واكثر رغبه في التقرب الى الله
بالطريقه التي يعتقد انها سليمه تمر به
الكلام ده كله قراره بتطبيق الشريعه
تطبق الشريعه لانه
تطبيق الشريعه بالنسبه لي يعني يحقق مصلحه
ولا يعني اه وما عليه بقرار في اسباب
شخصيه و اسباب سياسيه واسباب اقتصاديه
السبب الشخصي انا قلت لحضراتكم انه الواضح
مع تقدم العمر السلطان حسن
لم يعد نفس السلطان اللي كانت اخبار
وفضائح ومؤامرات وتم لا وسائل الاعلام في
كل مكان في العالم ممكن تكتب كده سلطان
بروناي يطلع لكم كلام كثير يعني اه عنه
الامر الثاني اذا ما بيقول حضراتكم انه هو
الرجل يستمد شرعيته من حركتين في كل الدول
الراعيه اللي هي تعتمد على مصدر للثروه
الطبيعيه بيعتمد على حاجتين
هي فكره توفير احتياجات الناس الاساسيه
انه الارض تطلع بطول الحكومه تاخذ العائد
تنفقه على مواطنيه المواطنين ما بيدفعوا
ضرائب ما بينفع اي نوع من الرسوم الاساسيه
يعني يعني الضرائب او اي شكل من اشكال
الضرائب وكمان انه كل الخدمات الاساسيه من
التعليم والرعايه الصحيه الى اخره ولدى
الحكومه بكثره والحكومه بتوقف كل العاملين
وبالتالي لماذا انخفضت ال ال ال المداخيل
تاتي انخفضت قدره الحكومه على توفير هذه
الخدمات يبدا السخط بالناس لمزيد البطاله
والناس مش لاقيين فرص عمل و مش لاقيين
نفس عنده مقدره ان يعيش نفسه اللي عطوها
ونسبه البطاله تجاوزت في 2017 2016 السبعه
في المائه هو يستمد شرعيته من ال قدره
الدوله على الوفاء باحتياجات المواطنين
بالشكل انا بقولها حضراتكم عليه الامر
الثاني من شرعيته الدينيه هو عامل زي حكام
كثير في العالم يستمد شرعيته من الاثنين
يعني مثلا لما تشوف السعوديه انه الملك في
السعوديه يستمد شرعيته من قدرته ومن قدره
من استخدام اموال البترول والغاز في
الانفاق على المواطنين بردو بنفس الاسلوب
الريح الامر الثاني انه خادم الحرمين
الشرفين الملك عبد الله في الاردن انه هو
ملك يعني اه ملك او سلطان او حاكم عالي
لكن ايضا يستمد الشرعيه الدينيه من كونوا
من اسره
من منا سره الشريف حسين وبالتالي هو كمان
ومن هو سيطره على الاراضي ال على المقدسات
في القدس
وهكذا كذلك السلطان حسن هو بيستمر نشرته
ايضا باعتباره مش بس هو السلطان والمناسبه
هو السلطان وهو وزير الدفاع رئيس الوزراء
ووزير الماليه ووزير الخارجيه ولكن ايضا
هو امام اه سلطنه بروناي فعنده وضع ديني
وهو راغب في ان يكون سرقه كامام تتسق مع
الحقيقه بين او يتسق مع الواقع ان يطبق
الشريعه عشان صورته تبقى متفقه مع وضعه في
الدستور
قرر الان لانه الان هو اكثر حاجه من اي
وقت مضى في انه هو يسيطر على الوضع
الداخلي اللي هو الناس المحبطه الناس اللي
هي خانقه على تغير الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
بانه يفرض اولا ال عقوبات رادعه الامر
التالي انه يعيش وفقا للصوره هو امام
سلطنه بروناي يعتقد وعلى فكره الكلام ده
مش جديد اللي بيتكلم عليها من التسعين انه
الشريعه الاسلاميه والاسلام قادر على ان
يكون حائط صد التعبير اللي استخدمه ضد
العولمه او ضد الانحرافات الكثيره اللي
بتنقل هذه العولمه عن طريق الانترنيت
وغيره الامر الثالث انه كمان مش بس هيبقى
يعني انه يؤمن او السيطره على الاوضاع هو
كمان على سبيل الردع لكن كمان على سبيل
المغازله تطبيق الشريعه في غاز ال ال
المحافظين اللي موجودين او المتدينين
والمتشددين او ال يعني سواء في بروناي او
في الدول المجاوره
اضف الى كل انه في سبب اقتصادي بما انه
الدول الغربيه لم تعد مهتمه بالاستثمار في
بعد ان نفذت نفذت يعني اه اه خزائنها او
ارضها من الطاقه هو يامل بتطبيق الشريعه
مش بس انه يحقق مصلحه سياسيه ولا انه يرضي
نفسه على المستوى الشخصي
لكن كمان مصلحه اقتصاديه لانه دول اخرى في
اندونيسيا وماليزيا ادركت الاف من سوء
واسع جدا
اقتصادي يمكن ان يكون جاذبا لملايين احنا
عندنا في جنوب في في منطقه اسيا او جنوب
شرق اسيا ان اكثر من تسعمائه مليون مسلم
هؤلاء بيمثلوا السوق واعد جدا سواء في
مجال الصرافه الاسلاميه وفي مجال السياحه
الدينيه وفي مجال المطاعم الحلال
الصغيره انه يكون لها مصدر للدخل لاكتساب
هذه الشريحه بعد ان نفذت اه مصادرها
الاساسيه او عندما تنفذ يعني اخر قطره
انا لا اقول الكلام دا ممكن يكون السبب
الاساسي في مساله الشريعه لو هي المساله
ايمان فقط بمساله الشريعه كان امام
السلطان المثقف الحكم البلد لعشرات
السنوات عشرات الامور الاخرى اللي كانت
تعود بالنفع ولا تك عنه في اه في صدام مع
دول العالم الاخرى انه يختار من تطبيق
الشريعه بدايات مساله تحقيق العداله
الاجتماعيه تحقيق العداله السياسيه فتح
الحريات اه يعني الانفاق عن العلم امور
كثيره جدا كان ممكن يخطئها اه ك اه اه
يعني كمدخل تطبيق الشريعه لكن هو لا يقرر
الانفاق على البحث العلمي يبقى زي مثلا اه
المانيا اذا قرر ان يكون اكثر عدلا
وديمقراطيين ان يكون زي زي بريطانيا
ايه اللي ممكن ي يعني يكون
ويغازل بشكل مباشر الاوساط المتشدده هو
انه يعلن تطبيق الحدود اللي وقطع يد
السارق
وقتل ربما او حتى الموت للزاني اول ممارس
الرذائل الاخرى وبالتالي مدخل اسهل لانها
الشرعيه ودعم وضعه السياسي وا كتاب
يعني اه اقتصاد يامل ان يعرضوا على نفس ال
اه
البترول والغاز يقول وفي انها انه ممكن
الخطوه ربما
تحفظ على عرش لسنوات اخرى قادمه له ولي
عهده لكن المؤكد انه لا يمكن ابدا ان يحقق
الهدف اللي هو اعلانهم من الفين وثمانيه
لما حط برنامج اسمه بروناي الفين وخمسه
وثلاثين والبرنامج في انه هو يكون في
سنغفوره الاسلاميه سنغافوره طبعا مثالا
للتقدم الازدهار الاقتصادي
لا يمكن ابدا ان نحقق له هذا الهدف اشكر
اول لقاء اخر ان شاء الله
ام
[موسيقى]